[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález en medio de
nuevos picos de contagio de
confinamiento y lentos avances de la
vacunación tres países de américa latina
se enfrentan al denominado super domingo
electoral ecuador realizará la segunda
vuelta presidencial entre andrés araus
visto como el heredero del correísmo de
tendencia socialista y guillermo lazo de
la derecha ecuatoriana por su parte perú
va a unas elecciones anticipadas
convocadas para poner fin a la espiral
de inestabilidad de esa crisis política
que ha dejado cuatro presidentes en
cuatro años unos comicios en donde no
hay claros favoritos pero lo que sí hay
es un descontento entre los ciudadanos y
mucha desconfianza en los procesos
electorales
por otra parte bolivia también va a la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
regionales cuatro departamentos
chuquisaca la paz tarija y pando
repetirán las votaciones de las
elecciones de gobernadores dado que el
pasado 7 de marzo ninguno de los
candidatos obtuvo la mayoría de los
votos
necesaria sobre su rival este es el
panorama en estos tres países veamos
importante domingo electoral para tres
países de américa latina perú se estaría
enfrentando a las elecciones más
fraccionadas de su historia tras la
convulsa destitución de martín vizcarra
al que siguieron tres presidentes en
sólo una semana los últimos sondeos
auguran un empate técnico entre cinco
candidatos si bien ninguno alcanzaría el
15% yonhy lescano keiko fujimori
verónica mendoza el economista hernando
de soto y el ex portero george forsyth
son los principales beneficiarios en las
encuestas pero aproximadamente el 30 por
ciento de los electores no tiene claro
por qué en votar la gestión de la
pandemia centrado el debate electoral y
desde ya se pronostica una segunda
vuelta ecuador ya llegó a esa segunda
vuelta para elegir a su nuevo presidente
tras el polémico recuento de la primera
vuelta que dejó fuera el candidato
indígena ya q pérez los ecuatorianos
deberán elegir entre el candidato
correísta andrés a daúd y el
centroderechista guillermo lasso la duda
ahora radica en la dirección que tomará
el voto indígena dividido entre la
opción abstencionista y el apoyo a
andrés a la vez la jornada se completará
con la según
vuelta de las elecciones regionales en
cuatro departamentos bolivianos la paz
chuquisaca pando y tarija
el oficialismo teme que el más pierda la
gobernación de la paz que podría pasar a
manos de jala ya el partido de la
expresidenta y es integrante del + eba
copa alcaldesa electa del alto
entretanto chile debía celebrar comicios
este fin de semana para elegir los
constituyentes que redactarán la nueva
constitución pero el senado finalmente
aprobó su aplazamiento para el 15 y 16
de mayo por el preocupante aumento de
contagios de kobe 19 en el país
así es como están las cosas y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
karen garzón directora de relaciones
internacionales de la universidad
internacional sek en ecuador nos atiende
desde la ciudad de quito la capital
ecuatoriana y también está con nosotros
cristian jaramillo él es politólogo y
analista internacional hace parte del
observatorio de reformas políticas de
américa latina' él se encuentra en la
ciudad de lima la capital de perú yo les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación y pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios en las redes
sociales les recuerdo estamos en
facebook y también no se encuentran en
instagram en donde de hecho hay una
pequeña encuesta y en twitter como
france24
arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate
efe 24 pues tenemos del panorama más
claro de estos tres países quiero
comenzar entonces con karen en la ciudad
de quito en ecuador y comenzamos
analizando el caso específico de ecuador
que se ven que usted se encuentra el
país en el que usted se encuentra karen
y hay mucha incertidumbre en el voto
está muy parejo para estos dos
candidatos para andrés arados
guillermo lasso está muy parejo y no es
muy claro quién puede ser el que tome la
delantera y llegue a la silla
presidencial allí en carondelet buenas
noches
buenas noches santiago muchísimas
gracias por la invitación a tu programa
buenas noches también a toda la
audiencia de france 24 efectivamente nos
encontramos frente a un escenario de
incertidumbre para esta segunda vuelta
no sabemos a ciencia cierta cuál de los
dos candidatos ganará si guillermo olaso
o andrés araus recordemos también lo
ocurrido en el año 2017 también en una
segunda vuelta donde tuvimos un
escenario muy similar entre correísmo y
anti correísmo en esta ocasión pues se
reeditar esta situación que tuvimos
extraños y nos enfrentamos a un
escenario complejo por la polarización y
también por la situación país el tema de
la crisis económica la crisis política
la crisis sanitaria esta triple crisis
nos ha afectado mucho como país y por
supuesto las y los ecuatorianos
acudiremos este domingo a las urnas
pensando en un mejor mañana pero también
con la preocupación de quién será él
el presidente de ecuador cristian en la
ciudad de lima la capital de perú
también le preguntó por el caso de
ecuador vamos a hablar del tema del tema
peruano más adelante quiero preguntarle
cuáles son esos ejes que usted ve que
son transversales para estas tres
elecciones no sé si usted está de
acuerdo conmigo en que hablamos de
pandemia crisis económica crisis social
y tal vez un descontento generalizado y
tal vez un común denominador entre
ecuatorianos peruanos y bolivianos en
estas elecciones
bueno solo sobre el último punto yo
diría que es un común denominador en
casi toda américa latina no existe un
gran descontento con los partidos
políticos existe un descontento con los
gobernantes y sobre todo en esta
coyuntura crítica la crisis sanitaria ha
revelado de que existen grandes
dificultades en diversos temas tanto
políticos como sociales y sobre todo
algo bastante curioso no el cambio de
ministros de salud constante que ha
tenido ecuador tanto calor como tanto
argentina tanto perú por por diversos
escándalos vinculados con el tema de las
vacunas el debate ahora es quien puede
ser el mejor líder o el líder más capaz
como para poder cambiar esta situación y
poder liderar esta situación a un mejor
cuerpo y las la el cob ins
indudablemente va a jugar un gran rol en
el tema electoral
karen regreso al caso ecuatoriano estas
elecciones del 11 de abril están
precedidas por unas acusaciones de
fraude que tuvieron lugar en esa primera
vuelta unas acusaciones que fueron
lanzadas desde la candidatura de jacko
pérez que terminó de tercero en esa
primera ronda con el 19 punto 39 por
ciento de los votos hay mucha
incertidumbre en torno al sistema
electoral sobre todo porque los grupos
indígenas ecuatorianos ven que los votos
no fueron los que dejaron por fuera ya q
pérez de esta segunda vuelta sino que
fue el cn en ese largo período de tiempo
que se tomó para contar los votos para
hacer los recuentos y recuentos
solamente en 30 actas de votación cuando
ellos pedían cerca de 200 que fueron
recortadas
santiago es muy importante que se tome
en cuenta que luego de lo sucedido en la
primera vuelta electoral para esta
segunda vuelta se pondrá a prueba la
fortaleza de la institucionalidad
electoral actualmente el consejo
nacional electoral cuenta con un 13 por
ciento de aceptación de credibilidad y
eso es algo que justamente el consejo
nacional electoral tendrá que hacer
frente es uno de los mayores retos para
estas elecciones por supuesto en la
primera vuelta hubo mucha incertidumbre
muchas dudas y no se brindaron certezas
por un hecho que ocurrió adicionalmente
el día de la jornada electoral el 7 de
febrero a las 9 de la noche cuando el
consejo nacional electoral proclamó
anunció un muestreo que no había
completado el 100% en cuanto al conteo
rápido de esta forma se anunció
anticipadamente que el segundo lugar lo
ocupaba efectivamente el candidato y aqu
pérez
el partido pachakutik y en un tercer
lugar se ubicaba el candidato guillermo
lasso minutos después aproximadamente 10
minutos se indicó que la muestra se
había estabilizado y que el candidato
guillermo lazo se ubicaba en un segundo
lugar esto por supuesto no no puede
ocurrir con un organismo electoral quien
debe ejercer una responsabilidad brindar
certezas y dar seguridad a la ciudadanía
actualmente nos encontramos también en
de cara a esta segunda vuelta en un
escenario donde el partido pachakutik ha
llamado al voto nulo esto genera que las
personas que en una primera vuelta
votaron superbien temente convencidos
por su candidato pues tengan esta opción
de voto nulo recordando que
históricamente en ecuador desde el
retorno de la democracia hemos tenido en
el año 1992 justamente en la segunda
vuelta entre sixto durán ballén y jaime
nebot le obtuvimos un récord
histórico del 13 por ciento de voto nulo
pero esto ha sido algo muy muy puntual y
podría ser una elección donde
efectivamente se supere este porcentaje
histórico cristian analizando los dos
países el ecuador y perú vemos este
llamado al voto nulo que hacen los
diferentes sectores de los grupos
indígenas y también muchos seguidores de
jacko pérez el mismo ya que pérez
también hizo un llamado a ese voto nulo
pero pero según el análisis no es un
llamado al voto nulo porque los dos
candidatos no funcionan sino como voto
castigo al sistema electoral ecuatoriano
por lo sucedido en ese en ese supuesto
fraude de la primera vuelta como qué
lectura le hace usted
efectivamente si uno revisa por ejemplo
en las cifras de latinobarómetro de las
américas acerca de la confianza que los
latinoamericanos tenemos para con las
instituciones nuestra conciencia es
bastante baja el producto de ellos
nuestros organismos electorales
usualmente son independientes o
constitucionalmente autónomos y en
consecuencia siempre están en la mira
el accionar del cn en momentos ha sido
cuestionable pero también hay que
recordar de que generar elecciones en
medio de pandemia es un proceso bastante
complejo no ha significado es crear
elaborar y ejecutar nuevos protocolos
protocolos de prevención contra el kobe
y han también supuesto un reto para este
tipo de instituciones tanto en perú como
en ecuador y tanto en bolivia es
nuevamente volvemos al mismo tema de la
crisis sanitaria ha puesto a prueba a
todas las instituciones ahora el tema de
la desconfianza el tema de la poca
credibilidad hacia el sistema en general
es algo sistémico que nuestros partidos
políticos en toda américa latina están
en crisis y en consecuencia
es mucho más fácil es mucho más fácil
observar en distintos en distintos
contextos las mismas situaciones se
siguen los políticos de los mandatarios
baja es muy baja en general en la
mayoría de los países de la región y
también diría que en diferentes partes
del mundo
karen aquí estamos de nuevo en 3a antes
a dos caras de la moneda entre regresar
al socialismo que dejó el correísmo en
ecuador que se suponía debía continuar
con lenin moreno pero que él tomó
distancia y decidió llevar un gobierno
por su parte aquí podemos enfrentarnos a
un nuevo gobierno de tendencia
socialista correísta con con árabes que
también ya ha dado algunos indicios de
que de llevar el socialismo pero a su
forma y entendimiento y la otra cara de
un estado más capitalista y abierto a la
economía de mercado con el otro
candidato como ve usted entonces hay las
cargas de fuerzas de esos dos partidos
políticos y sistemas políticos
santiago nos enfrentamos a dos modelos
distintos de estado y de economía araos
por un lado promete ser un estado
planificador y regulador de la economía
mientras que el candidato guillermo
lasso ha manifestado que será un estado
subsidiario de la iniciativa privada
efectivamente son dos caras de la moneda
que auguran dos escenarios muy
diferentes para nuestro país y por eso
también se explica el alto grado de
polarización que vivimos actualmente
efectivamente hay un porcentaje del
electorado que nunca respaldaría a un
candidato de el ex presidente el ex
mandatario rafael correa y hay otro
porcentaje del electorado que cuenta con
un voto muy fuerte para el candidato
correísta y que se opone al candidato
que lo han tachado por así decirlo como
banquero recordemos que históricamente
pues nuestro país tuvo un feriado
bancario en la situación
muy impactante en el año 2000 y eso está
en la memoria en el imaginario de
nuestra población entonces ambos
candidatos se enfrentan en esta lid
electoral con pros y contras ante los
ojos del electorado
cristian del ego a dar la palabra porque
vamos a entrar al tema de perú quiero
cerrar con karen este capítulo de
ecuador y los retos que va a tener el
mandatario que llegue a la silla
presidencial ecuatoriana evidentemente
hasta la pandemia y la recuperación
económica del país
primero eso y para el cierre hablar de
la importancia del voto indígena que en
este caso pues va a tener un alto
impacto en la definición de ese de ese
presidente en ecuador karen
bueno el voto indígena efectivamente va
a sumar para esta segunda vuelta pero
recordemos que sea cual sea el
electorado y me refiero por esto a las
14 candidaturas que hubieron y el
electorado que los respaldo en una
primera vuelta nos enfrentamos hoy por
hoy a una segunda vuelta yo no creo que
en la mayoría no puedo generalizar pero
que estos votos se vayan a transferir de
manera directa es decir que sí
pachakutik convoca un voto nulo no creo
que el 19% del electorado que votó por
pachakutik vaya a votar efectivamente no
lo serán entre voto nulo voto blanco y
por una u otra candidatura y la primera
pregunta perdón santiago te voy a pedir
que me la réplica porque sube una
interferencia del internet
y quería que me contara los retos que
puede tener ese nuevo mandatario que
llegue a la silla presidencial del
ecuador más allá de los evidentes que
son la recuperación económica y hacerle
frente a la pandemia de kobe 19 que más
problemas tiene ecuador en este momento
bueno nos enfrentamos efectivamente a la
misma situación que experimentan todos
los países de américa latina y es poder
adquirir de manera pronta un porcentaje
significativo de vacunas tenemos la
triple crisis que yo te comentaba un
sistema sanitario completamente
colapsado una crisis económica profunda
que responde justamente a un
sobreendeudamiento que hubo hace diez
años de correísmo y que este gobierno en
cierta medida pues ha tratado de
controlar buscando financiamiento con el
fondo monetario internacional y entre
otras instituciones multilaterales pero
yo creo que la principal preocupación
por parte de la población es
efectivamente el trabajo hay datos
oficiales de cepal que indican que 3.2
millones de personas en nuestro país
habrían pasado en la época de la
pandemia
a pobreza y pobreza extrema estamos
hablando de una pobreza multidimensional
que genera muchos problemas sociales y
creo que la principal preocupación va a
ser esta la economía y el tema social y
por supuesto del de la pandemia tengo
que dejar el tema de ecuador ahí sé que
quedan muchas aristas en el aire para
luego pasar a analizar el tema de perú y
comienzo la ronda a la inversa entonces
comienzo con cristian en la ciudad de
lima christian haciendo lectura de
análisis de la situación en perú y de
cara a estas elecciones presidenciales
la única certeza es que va a haber una
segunda vuelta en pero porque están muy
divididas las intenciones de voto en
este país cuéntenos cuál es el panorama
general que hay allí esta gran cantidad
de duplas de fórmulas presidenciales que
ninguna se alza como favorita
si primero una pequeña precisión las
elecciones peruanas no son mis
decisiones anticipadas es algo que
mencionaste pero pero no es no es tan
correcto son elecciones que se están
cumpliendo según el calendario existió
una propuesta de anticipar las
elecciones hacia algunos años para salir
de la crisis política pero está
propuesto en hombres pero entonces
nuestras elecciones del 2021 que
coinciden con las elecciones
bicentenario son las elecciones normales
gracias por la declaración con respecto
a el escenario político prácticamente
seis empates entonces son 18 los
candidatos son 18 en las fórmulas
presidenciales hay seis empates posibles
según las últimas encuestas lo cual es
una gran incertidumbre no tenemos desde
extremos muy grandes como como es pedro
castillo por ejemplo como lo es rafael
lópez aliaga tanto la derecha como la
izquierda y también tenemos candidatos
que vuelven a popular
a intentar ganarnos como keiko fujimori
en su momento que ya es su tercera
postulación a la presidencia entonces
por el momento no se puede hacer una
lectura tan no es fácil hacer una
lectura por la indecisión misma de los
ciudadanos y porque el voto se
distribuye casi equitativamente entre
todas las opciones a qué se debe esa esa
indecisión de los de los ciudadanos
peruanos para estos comicios a que hay
muchos candidatos y las opciones son
muchas entonces no hay algo definido o
es un síntoma de ese descontento social
que están experimentando los peruanos
después de haber tenido cuatro
presidentes en cuatro años y tener
cierta desconfianza en su clase política
y en su sistema
yo me apuntaría más s los segundos no es
un tema más de desconfianza porque la
oferta política ha sido casi la misma el
tener 18 18 candidatos no es algo
extraño en las elecciones peruanos en la
anterior elección el número fue casi
similar la diferencia está en que la
crisis sanitaria y la crisis política
que vive perú desde el 2016 ha
arrastrado a varias figuras políticas
existen varios partidos que
evidentemente se han desgastado a lo
largo del tiempo que ya no son opciones
tan válidas en consecuencia el ciudadano
en general está eligiendo por más o
menos la opción que
prefiere ok lo que más le conviene en su
momento y también existe un gran colchón
de voto en blanco de un gran colchón de
indecisos en consecuencia la elección
básicamente se va a decidir si no es en
la fila va a ser un día o dos días antes
de la seriedad los de abril también
algunas de las informaciones y las notas
que tengo acá dicen algunas de las
encuestas que tradicionalmente en perú
el 40% del electorado elige por quién va
a votar en la última semana de previa a
la fecha de las elecciones o sea que
estamos en el momento importante en que
los peruanos están tomando sus
decisiones de cara a depositar el voto
el próximo domingo cullen pasó con usted
entonces hacer el análisis general de la
situación estamos hablando de los
factores acá muy importantes en pero la
credibilidad y la desconfianza que hay
por parte de los de los ciudadanos en
toda la clase política y la credibilidad
en el sistema eso cómo se puede
reconstruir eso cómo se puede volver a
ganar por parte de los ciudadanos es muy
difícil porque además en una realidad
los peruanos ya lo decía cristian es
generalizada en américa latina'
karen le puso le puso metal al micrófono
no la estamos oyendo ahora sí muchas
graves disculpas
muchas gracias santiago por tu pregunta
y creo que la respuesta es que la
democracia debe ser repensada por parte
de los partidos y movimientos políticos
no sólo en perú sino también
evidenciamos esto creo yo en todos los
países a nivel mundial y es que lo que
nosotros necesitamos es
representatividad por parte de los
políticos que lleguen al poder la
población no siente que sus necesidades
son atendidas por parte de estos
políticos cuando ya están en el
ejercicio de su cargo y esto es algo que
por supuesto el electorado castigará en
las urnas y que también en el caso
peruano vemos que ha tenido una una
crisis política muy importante muy
significativa no sólo para el país sino
también me atrevo a decir que para la
región y en ese sentido esto es lo que
evidencia el desinterés que ha tenido él
con estas elecciones
cristian viendo a los candidatos que
están allí en perú en su país para
llegar a la silla presidencial vemos
figuras conocidas usted ya los nombraba
keiko fujimori quien aspira por tercera
vez a la presidencia del país acusadas
señaladas estaba en prisión preventiva
ha sido acusada de corrupción por estar
relacionada con la trama de odebrecht
está allí en perú
elezkano también señalado por algunos
casos
ollanta humala que ya fue presidente que
aspira otra vez a hacerlo la corrupción
nuevamente como eje central de las
campañas presidenciales allí en perú los
candidatos señalados de corrupción y
vuelven a presentarse y la gente vota
por ellos
en parte de este tipo de comportamientos
pueden parecer algo ilógico si uno lo
mira con con otros ojos pero si tienes
la misma oferta política todos los años
evidentemente no te queda
mucha opción no no tienes mucho mucho
mucho manejo mucha capacidad y los
partidos políticos históricamente en el
perú no han sido tan democráticos son
más individualistas son más son partidos
que básicamente están a favor de un
líder y no importa si ese líder
tiene tantas denuncias o entraba en la
cárcel o ya está desprestigiado
entonces claro suena bastante ilógico
pero dentro de lo irracional que pueden
parecer lamentablemente es la oferta
política que ofreció ahora la política
peruana ahora cómo cambiar esta oferta
política han habido primeros pasos de
reforma por ejemplo ya tenemos las
primarias abiertas simultáneas y
obligatorias que son aplicar en perú en
los siguientes años y esto espera que se
democraticen más los partidos políticos
y que nuevas caras y nuevas opciones
puedan poder subir
cristian la gran apuesta para perú
veamos el escenario de ecuador que tiene
muchas diferencias con perú pero en perú
la gran apuesta es darle estabilidad
política al país cuatro presidentes en
cuatro años estas elecciones la persona
va a tener el escenario y la
gobernabilidad necesaria para poderle
dar estabilidad al país como lo vio
usted
lamentablemente yo creo que no porque
una cosa que se está escapando en el
debate político y el debate público en
general es que este escenario de cuatro
presidentes en tan solo un mandato se
generó a través de la causal de
incapacidad moral que existe dentro de
nuestra constitución nuestra
constitución contempla de que si el
congreso considera que el presidente es
incapaz moralmente vaya dios a saber qué
significa eso lo pueden bajar y todos
los presidentes han cuando los tres
presidentes han ido cayendo por ésta por
llamado a esta a esta a esta causa no
hay un debate a través de esta reforma
no entonces el que llegue al poder
tienen las mismas opciones de salir del
poder al aplicarse esta causal esta
cuestión tiene que reformarse
urgentemente y sin embargo no es parte
del debate los candidatos no lo han
comentado básicamente no se habla de
este tema que básicamente que fue lo que
nos trajo a la crisis política que
sufrimos desde el 2017
o sea que retomando sus palabras en dos
años en un año podríamos sentar a través
a la salida de un presidente peruano y
otra vez inestabilidad
hay un tema interesante aquí en la
región y en estos tres países que se
enfrentan a comicios regionales y
generales es la polarización karen un
tema común que ha venido presentándose
en comicios alrededor del mundo que
lectura si usted de la polarización para
ecuador en su caso personal y para perú
que es el caso que estamos analizando
bueno en el caso ecuatoriano podemos ver
que hay una crisis de partidos en
movimientos políticos que justamente se
traduce en el número excesivo que vimos
para la primera vuelta electoral que en
nuestro caso fue de 16 candidaturas y yo
me atrevería a decir que en el caso
peruano que también lo compartimos con
el ecuatoriano es esta falta de
representatividad que te comentaba
santiago en la anterior pregunta la
población no se siente identificada y
esto genera un sinnúmero de
inconvenientes porque por supuesto
cuando los mandatarios llegan al poder
empiezan a ejecutar políticas públicas
que no responden a las necesidades
reales de la población
y ahí viene justamente todo lo que
nosotros vimos en octubre de 2019 en
ecuador lo que vimos también meses
después en chile en perú entre otros
países y es esta no solo desconfianza
institucionalidad y falta de
representatividad sino que vemos
la ciudadanía en general que los
gobernantes pues no responden a estas
necesidades que tenemos como población
importante destacar ese punto de la
representatividad tal vez es otro de los
temas centrales para la región como lo
dice y karen quiero que miremos el caso
de bolivia que es un caso pues un poco
más particular son unas elecciones
regionales cuatro gobernaciones de
cuatro departamentos están allí en juego
pero sí son muy significativas para los
partidos políticos que se están jugando
allí la balanza de poder en el país
también después de un gran remezón
político que vimos allí con la salida de
evo morales- la llegada del gobierno
interino el regreso de evo morales y el
triunfo de arce en los comicios comienzo
con cristian en la ciudad de lima cuál
es el análisis que usted hace entonces
en general de esta situación en bolivia
el más buscando volver a ganar terreno
mantenerse como la fuerza de más peso
político en este país que análisis hace
usted
yo creo que estas elecciones por más son
nacionales que sean es una prueba para
el más no es que es tratar de comprobar
si existe vida después de bombo la evo
morales existió vida después de morales
con la elección de arte y ahora quieren
afianzar sin nacionalizar más el partido
evidentemente no es lo mismo este el más
de hace tres años cuatro años atrás no
es el más de ahora así que si son nuevos
liderazgos que están compitiendo por el
poder tanto internamente como
externamente pero los resultados que que
van a arrojar van a ver si hay y
comprobar la fortaleza de este
movimiento no sí sí lo que construyó evo
morales a lo largo de los años sigue
vigente o si tal vez el las y los
ciudadanos optan por algunas otras
opciones
karen y también están juego allí en
bolivia la construcción de una oposición
fuerte una oposición ya sea de varios
partidos o que se consolide y sea una un
poco más para hacerle frente al más al
movimiento al socialismo que como ya lo
dice christian está tratando de ganar
terreno y fortalecerse y demostrar
no fue solamente un proyecto de evo
morales como viste el papel de la de la
oposición sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
los antecedentes de los últimos meses
con este remezón político
justamente santiago consideró que el
movimiento al socialismo más buscará el
control de las principales gobernaciones
que en primera vuelta pues fueron
esquivas por ahí se les escaparon y en
este sentido creo que la oposición para
ahondar a muchos esfuerzos para poder
obtener estas gobernaciones y de esta
forma poder conseguir que el electorado
vote por por la oposición ahora hay algo
muy importante y creo que estará marcado
para los tres países bolivia perú
ecuador y es este deterioro
institucional económico y político que
hace prefigurar que las movilizaciones
sociales serán parte de las condiciones
de gobernabilidad de los nuevos
mandatarios algo que nos diferencia en
cuanto al partido mas en bolivia y digo
nos diferencia porque en ecuador el
partido alianza país dependía del
caudillo rafael correa
en el partido más de bolivia pues vemos
que no depende exclusivamente de un
caudillo sino que es un conjunto de
movimientos sociales de fuerzas
políticas que respaldan este partido
entonces creo que indistintamente de que
esté evo morales- o no pues tiene está
esta fortaleza el movimiento más
cristian rápidamente ya para el cierre
el papel de los organismos
internacionales ya están en ecuador y en
perú los observadores de organismos como
la oea en bolivia también pero en
bolivia fueron sumamente criticados por
haber participado en este recuento de
los votos han sido señalados por
participar en ese supuesto golpe de
estado que perpetraron allí en bolivia
los organismos internacionales pierden
también credibilidad en estos procesos
electorales
yo no diría tanto eso no yo diría que el
papel de los organismos electorales es
reafirmar lo que hace un organismo un
organismo electoral interno dentro del
país el organismo electoral nacional
tiene problemas el organismo
internacional lo que tienen que hacer es
evidenciar esos problemas
el mostrar los errores no significa
llamar a la desestabilización
necesariamente ahora el papel de los
observadores es un papel fundamental en
las democracias latinoamericanas
democracias que no son tan consolidadas
que no son tan sólidas tener ojos
externos y tener una visión externa
permite no sólo advertir posibles
fraudes sino también advertir posibles
deficiencias
las misiones deben ser la versión
electoral siempre desarrollando un
informe que al final entrega los países
y casi siempre esas recomendaciones no
son bien entendidas no habría que tal
vez hacer un poco más de autocrítica en
lo que recibimos y en lo que podemos
hacer para mejorarlo
pues así está a grandes rasgos este
panorama electoral en suramérica de cara
a este domingo super domingo electoral
en ecuador perú y bolivia ecuador y perú
van a elecciones presidenciales ecuador
en segunda vuelta pero en primera vuelta
y bolivia enfrenta una repetición la
segunda vuelta también de unas
elecciones regionales para unas
gobernaturas de algunos departamentos
allí a karen garzón en la ciudad de
quito muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros haber hecho el análisis y
compartir con nosotros las opiniones y
cristian jaramillo en la ciudad de lima
en perú también gracias por haber estado
con nosotros sigan dejando sus preguntas
y sus comentarios en las redes sociales
siga con nosotros
[Música]